so mood is a mood man it's a mood what
mood are you in today
i'm in a great mood bro i'm i'm just
getting good news all day
what does it feel like to to start
seeing your numbers just climb and climb
and climb like
when you saw people just cashing on the
song um
it feels good man i like i've never been
one to like
been super to be super like ah i need to
get the number one or i need to
sell this many albums but for me it's
more just like a sign from the universe
like
yo you're doing the right thing people
people like this this is making people's
lives
better so just keep doing it yeah i mean
everybody gets into this thing for all
different reasons
but what's like your motivation you said
the getting the numbers isn't
isn't it so what is it for you i love
making music like
the fact i get to wake up every day and
and make music if i want to and that's
that's my career
i get to go see the world and and meet
incredible people and
and perform in front of my fans and just
share those moments together
i'm here for the process yeah you were
at usc for how long
like a year like a year was it killing
you every day that you were there and
not doing what you wanted to do
hold on i'm being attacked by bees
[Laughter]
um nah i was i was having a good time
there but
you know ultimately my heart was telling
me every day like you said like yo
music is it music is it you should be at
the studio right now so i just had to
listen
listen to myself and what was the
conversation but uh with your family
like about that
it was it wasn't too bad like they
understood my mom she was tripping out a
little bit at first like
no like you got a full scholarship
because in theory it sounds crazy right
like
yeah i got a full scholarship to usc and
i dropped out to become a rapper like
if if most people told you that you'd be
like man this kid messed up but
it ended up working out well for me but
i mean i imagine if you're
the type of person that get a full
scholarship then you know that you're
applying yourself
just to something else right well we
know that but not everyone else uh
thinks that same way
right right right so when you look back
to like a year ago a year and a half ago
uh to the way life was you know how much
is it different and is it so
is it like so crazy that it's so
different um honestly
i think it feels uh it feels
pretty normal just because of the whole
pandemic and everything like
let's say it was a regular year i
probably would be on tour right now if i
had a song this big i'll probably
be in the club popping bottles or
whatever like whatever you're supposed
to do when you when you get a song this
big i don't know it's my first time
so now that you actually have been in
this situation where you're
you're kind of like the song is so big
but you actually can't go do all that
stuff
until you got to just sit and chill on
it what have you been thinking about
what you're going to do when you
can go do that i just want to tour so
bad like
i i've only been out the country a
couple times and that was for the first
time last summer
and i know i see my song going up in uk
and korea and all these canada all these
different places i'm like
i want to go there like my song is big
there in a place i've never even been
like that's not right i need to go check
out what's up with that
what's the craziest place in the world
that you thought i would never
you know like you didn't factor in maybe
two years ago that that place
would be loving your music and that you
could actually go there and see people
that don't even speak english
like singing and rapping back to you
where is that place
man probably like uh
everyone surprises me like everywhere
from like albania to
korea to japan to to norway like
it's like phases like every month it'll
be like yo we love you from spain we
love you from spain
and the next one's like italy so every
time it's a new place it really just
it's a genuine surprise every time
what was the last regular job that you
had before you started doing this
last regular job i had was the summer
before i went to college and i was a
basketball coach at lagarza
i always liked this basketball camp like
you teach kids how to play
yeah so i imagine that that's not one of
those jobs where you're like i can't do
this anymore that actually sounds like a
lot of fun
it was cool i mean the only problem like
was we had to do like little report
cards
and like if you had 12 kids on your team
that's boom
18 look like 10 minutes per report card
you're spending like two hours just
writing report cards for these kids but
it did it was it was a good time i liked
everything else about it
are you getting messages now from those
kids that you were teaching basketball
that are like
whoa not they always put me with the
kindergartners and the first graders so
uh
they wouldn't be able to tell i wasn't
actually good at basketball
i don't think they're old enough yet to
be reaching out
um you talked about like how important
tik tok
has been in terms of like getting
singles noticed and then how like
wild it is when it's when it's doing
this kind of
without tick tock right like what is how
much of a role has to talk played in
getting you to where you're at now i
mean tick tock is
it's a it's a piece of the puzzle you
know i think a lot of people especially
now
just like to say like oh it's all
tick-tock because
that's the newest freshest thing but you
can't just do well on tick tock like you
you got to have the ig right too you got
to have the the youtube right the
twitter
it's real comprehensive but in my story
personally like me
being a part of that community and a
part of that culture as it
became what it is that was incredibly uh
important you know because they showed a
lot of love just because i was showing a
lot of love
yeah as each of your singles gets like
progressively bigger and bigger
and you work towards releasing el dorado
do you
feel like a lot of pressure to make sure
that this is a
big deal that this really hits um
before i felt more pressure but now that
i got most of the album done i'm like
damn these are the best songs i've made
in my entire life like we're good we're
good so
i'm always working ahead on the next
steps and that definitely lets me
not feel the pressure so what is it
going to be like what's that what's it
going to sound like
i mean it's everything that that uh that
i showed you all i could do together
pretty much with dropped out of college
the ep
i wanted to prove i could do pop i could
do rap i could do rock i could do
alternative and now it's like me taking
little bits and pieces from all these
different genres and sounds and blending
them to make some of them out
where do ideas come from like how many
of your song ideas come from just
chilling out like playing video games or
something
um mood that was that's how that came
like i wasn't even trying to
to make a song i was just playing video
games that one came but
all my best songs i found um the
inspiration comes outside of the studio
whether that's
me just having someone say like a phrase
and i'm like whoa that was hot or like
me thinking of a melody and just voice
memoiring and working on it in the
studio but life is the greatest
inspiration there is
yeah now when you think about um moving
forward and collaborating with people
the more you get noticed obviously the
more people are gonna
you know send you messages about about
bigging you up or whatever who do you
want to
collaborate with drake
[Laughter]
number one you ever see that uh dj
khaled talking about what it's like
to collaborate with drake that's not
what you do what do you say
he tells his whole experience about
coming to toronto
and how when drake calls and says what
are you doing tomorrow he's like i'm on
a plane in toronto
obviously and like how he gets treated
you gotta you gotta
see it it's fine check it out yeah check
it out
so your name is golden 24k golden is
that like
was it a nickname nah so my my real name
is golden
uh like on my birth certificate and
everything and when our first rapping i
just went by golden but it was kind of
hard to like find like when you google
golden search on spotify like a bunch of
other stuff comes up so i was
i had to add something to make it
different so i added the 24k because
that's the most pure form of gold
and this music is me trying to be this
art is me trying to be the most pure
form of myself
this art is me being the most pure form
of myself so it only made sense and then
i had to get rid of the e
because it was taken on instagram
already
so given that you love the process and
that you're a fan of the process when
you think about like
because you're only 19 right when you
think about like where you're gonna be
at 25
we're going to be out at 30 like
what do you see like in terms of
milestones
i mean i i just know that it's going to
get better every year but that's
that's one thing i've really learned is
that the
the more you know the more you realize
the less you know
my my schedule came changed completely
in the span of two weeks
so how am i supposed to know what's
supposed to happen five years from now
when i'm 25 like
i really have no idea but i know i want
to make more great music
i know i want to start acting and
getting into tv shows and movies
i know i want to start doing fashion and
spreading my drip to the world spreading
the swag to the world
and i know i want to do some cool
business stuff too and just find
creative solutions to improve people's
lives so
if i can make progress on any of those
things from now
until the time i die i'm gonna be a
happy man do you know what your
fashion line's gonna be called yet no
i've this is it's not planned out at all
this is just something i know that's
gonna happen
because i have too much sauce to not
share with the world